Eric Larson's books read like a 21st
century hit list and have sold millions
of copies devil in the White City
Isaac storm in the garden of beasts and
dead wake to name just a few
his latest effort is called a splendid
and the vile a saga of Churchill family
and defiance during the Blitz it takes a
new look at what may have been the
defining year of the 20th century after
Winston Churchill became prime minister
of Britain Churchill had two
all-consuming world-saving goals
hold off Adolf Hitler and seduce
Franklin Roosevelt's he got plenty of
help the images are unforgettable
beginning in the fall of 1940 London was
subjected to a brutal campaign of
bombing by Nazi forces it was called the
Blitz as Western Europe fell Britain
held the line and Winston Churchill led
the charge to keep calm and carry on
I have nothing you up blood toil 80
years later Eric Larson's retelling of
these events may be the most riveting
account yet the day he became Prime
Minister was the best day of his life no
matter that the world was going to hell
at the same time Larsen says he got the
idea to write about London by moving to
New York about five years ago he left
his longtime home on the west coast to
settle in Manhattan there was something
he couldn't stop thinking about when I
got to the city where I got this really
vivid sense of how different 9/11 had to
be for the city of New York for
residents of the city of New York the
smoke the sirens the ambulance was the
whole thing plus the sense of violations
in your home city had been attacked and
I started thinking well then how did how
could anyone have survived the bombing
of London during World War two
[Music]
the first phase of the London bombing
was 57 consecutive nights followed by an
even more intensifying series of raids
for six months after that in London in
that period it was a certainty that
someone somewhere in London would die
whether you yourself would be killed
that night dependent solely on luck how
could I maybe I could write about that
and how would I get out that's I thought
about doing a family in London and I
thought well why not the quintessential
family Churchill and his family and his
advisers how did they actually do it I
speak you for the first time Prime
Minister Larsen begins with the day
Churchill became Prime Minister his
choice to focus on the year that follows
and not the full 90 years that Churchill
lived leads to a blistering pace as a
writer I mean this is like a narrative
pod that is just about perfect it starts
May 10 1940 it ends May 10th 1941
I had my window and when you have your
window you look at things that maybe
other scholars ignore because they're
after something else and what do you
think you found about him that others
haven't I think putting it all together
in this one period gives a richer sense
of the broadchurch on the frivolity the
the courage and also the fact that he
did not do this alone he had a very
close circle of advisers he relied
heavily on those advisers those advisers
include Frederick Lindemann a physicist
and intellectual who almost no one could
stand but Churchill considered essential
and Max Aitken Lord Beaverbrook not just
one of the all-time great names but a
newspaper publisher who Churchill put in
charge of aircraft production and he had
his family he has family to worry about
but his family also supported him so I
think of anything what I've managed to
do is provide this much more vivid sense
of how you actually go about dealing
with all this stuff the family members
Larsson focuses on include Churchill's
wife Clementine and Larson's favorite
character in the book Churchill's
youngest daughter Mary Mary Churchill 17
years old was this this lovely charming
smart diarist and I was very lucky that
her daughter Emma Soames gave me
permission to read and use her diary the
team that led Britain through its most
precarious year understood from the top
on down that transatlantic messaging was
everything let us go forward together
with our united great his audience is
not so much the British people as it is
the American people yes this is
something that Churchill understood very
literally from day one the only way
we're gonna win this is if America joins
the war and he tells his son Randolph
exactly that he says we're gonna prevail
by dragging America into the war nothing
is more certain than that every trace of
Hitler's death will be blotted from the
earth we interviewed Larson at the
headquarters of the International
Churchill Society in Washington DC at
George Washington University where Lee
[ __ ] is the executive director does
the world need more Churchill
biographies more Churchill writing
people ask that question all the time
why another book about Winston Churchill
and it's the same question that people
ask do we need another book about George
Washington or Napoleon or Abraham
Lincoln great figures of history command
are interested in attention and their
aspects of vignettes of history that we
can continue to examine and re-examine
the society is full of a wide range of
artifacts this is a photograph of the
cabinet War Rooms now called the
Churchill war rooms in London including
this famous picture of Churchill when he
wasn't cooperating for the camera until
the photographer took his cigar away
Churchill glared there's a high bar for
you for anything about Churchill and you
think Eric clear I think Eric Eric
definitely clears that you know Eric's a
wonderful storyteller and this is a
wonderful story everything that happened
there was no in that 12-month period
there was never a dull day or day when
something interesting and important
wasn't happening wherever the damage was
worst Churchill appeared
symbol of British boarded you he was
fully aware that everything that he did
had a symbolic effect when he you know
went and toured bombed out areas and
said we're gonna win we're gonna do this
thing people took heart from that and he
was aware at every turn what simple
gestures meant he knew there was a
theater to it he knew there was a
theater to it absolutely and he knew how
to play the part he knew how to play the
part he was born to play that part
victory at all cost victory in spite of
old Terra victory over long and hard the
road may be but without victory there is
no survival Wow
fascinating yeah the the other part
that's really fascinating about this
book is that he talks about the the
frivolity he mentioned that and
Churchill he danced he's saying it the
horrific things happening such serious
things happening but he maintained a
sense of humor
and he goes into this in the book quite
a bit well the key people laughing and
smiling in the face of all this horror
and what away with words success is not
final failure is not fatal it is the
courage to continue that counts what a
motto for life
there it is mobilizing the English
language yeah ending it into battle yeah
and if you're going through hell keep
going everyone has his day in some days
lasts longer than others
what a guy gonna self-help classes